John Fugelsang is a comedian host of
tell me everything on Sirius XM insight
and a good buddy of mine John it took a
while but we've got you on the show
thank you very much team it's a pleasure
to be back on your show we really should
have recorded what happened for these
last six or eight minutes because I
think it's pretty good for your viewers
you didn't record what just happened we
had a little miscommunication whether we
were doing this at 11:30 a.m. or p.m.
long story short we just followed you as
you ran across the Sirius XM hallway
with your laptop screaming like a crazy
person well the good news is my evening
is now free I thought we were taping I
thought you were taping at 5:30 p.m.
your time
so 8:30 p.m. your time so I apologize
for the for the poor grasp of the
details but my defense is that I went to
public school thank you I'm bringing you
on to defend liberalism to defend the
left and we've already had a time
problem which has set us up here but
first let before we get into anything so
you are at Sirius XM that's where your
show is you actually tape your show out
of my old studio is that correct
oh they no it's not when I first met you
it was a very different studio and I was
doing it from they just move this to
another one and they're remodeling here
so but many times I have done pre taped
interviews in your old studio and I
always think of you and I always scour
the room for you know narcotics you
might have left off do you dedicate each
show to me I hope so in my heart I do
Dave in my heart I do all right well
let's get to it here because you are one
of my favorite comics you're actually
one of the only guys that can drag me to
do stand-up pretty much the only time I
do stand-up these days is when you say
all right I'm in town and I'm doing one
of my shows and you do these great
comedy nation shows that are mostly
about politics and free speech and
religion I mean all the things that I
like talking about so before we get into
comedy let's just talk about your
history because you have an incredible
upbringing your parents background go
Fugelsang 101 let's go oh my weird weird
to begin start at the beginning I'm an
actor I'm a stand-up I'm a
broadcaster I've I come from a curiously
Catholic background my parents are both
former Catholic clergy members my father
being a Franciscan brother my mother
being a nun who spent many years as a
nurse working with lepers in the jungles
of Malawi Africa
with a background like that I could
never afford the therapy I actually
needed so I got a theater and stand-up
and over the course of my career I've
I've hosted adult literacy shows for PBS
I have I've been murdered on CSI I've
gotten Drama League nominations for
off-broadway solo shows I've worked on
MSNBC Fox News and CNN I hosted my own
program for the late lamented Curran
channel I once got Mitt Romney's advisor
to call MIT an etch-a-sketch yeah and I
got George Harrison to play his final
on-camera performance and I hosted
America's Funniest Home Videos with
daisy fuentes so yeah it's a pretty
schizophrenic resume but that's not many
people can say they replaced Bob Saget
but you did oh I could never replace Bob
Saget even his wife agreed with that but
I was happy to take over for the show
for a little it was only gonna be for
like six weeks and I wound up being a
year and a half so it was a fun little
gig and it taught me that uh that wasn't
what I needed to yeah so I like doing a
little bit of the pedigree stuff because
it's important to know you know I feel
like there's so many Talking Heads and
nobody knows what their backgrounds are
what they studied where they came from
and it's it's nice knowing that so this
religious upbringing that you had when
did you sort of realize as you said you
couldn't afford therapy so you went into
acting and comedy when did you realize
that maybe some of the constructs of
religion weren't for you that's a great
question because I think that we you
know one thing that we don't talk about
too much is the separation of church and
faith the fact that religion and belief
are two completely different things and
religion is a culture of middle man
whereas faith is just between the
believer and the deity of their choice
you know I always have problems with
religion even when I was developed and
it wasn't until I I went to college and
my you at the NYU
applix enter and it was a very
progressive community I was actually
asked to help teach a course for
Congress along with the pastor and it
was a church that welcomed gay people
openly and I remember bringing my
parents to the church I went to in
college and they were so inspired by
seeing how gay couples were welcomed and
loved this is in the 80s and that kind
of made me realize well that's not the
usual policy for this unauthorized
fanclub of Jesus you know the more I was
really when I saw my dad give a lecture
in a college once about Martin Luther
and the Reformation that I was like why
are we
Catholic why aren't we lived through
these are all the critiques you have of
the Pope and so that was what really
made me be not a cat like I still
consider the Catholic Church to be my a
sexual orientation but um over the years
I found the farther I got away from
organized religion the more interested
in in theology and state by God and so
now I get to alienate everybody because
yes them think I'm a continent right so
you're making a really interesting
distinction there so you're not into
organized religion as it stands but you
are a believer correct yeah I'm a
believer sure ah but I don't think God's
an invisible man with a beard and a
penis in the sky you throws down a
lightning bolts when he's in a moody
situation you read the Old Testament
it's like the alcoholic step God and uh
you know it's like this big cosmic game
of candid camera and gods Allen Funt so
yeah I make a distinction I was asked to
go and come out bail show and debate
Jamie kills teen about atheism versus
belief and I was like well I'll never
tell an atheist they're wrong my
definition of faith doesn't involve
telling other people that they're wrong
um when I got to the studio they wanted
me to defend religion and I'm like no no
no all right like I'll defend anyone's
right to worship and as long as you're
not bothering anybody else's person or
property you're putting somebody down in
the name of Jesus then good for you god
bless find the fan club that works for
you but I'm not gonna defend religion
I'm gonna defend faith and belief and
they were like well no no don't do that
good
I said I'm sorry I can't and so Jamie
and I just told jokes and it got a
million hits on YouTube because I think
people are really tired of the whole my
god can beat of your god thing some of
the best Christians I know are atheists
some of the most godless I know yes can
go crazy you know I mean there's
fundamentalist atheists I mean I love
the Atheist handbook it's a great set of
rules for people who are tired of
religions set of rules for me it's like
you know my faith is such they believe
what you want to believe if it makes you
a better person
the Dalai Lama said the purpose of
religion is to uh the purpose of
religion is to improve yourself not
criticize others and that's kind of
where I come from although I do enjoy
mocking hypocrites it might think yeah
you love mocking hypocrites and that's a
lot about you know what your stand-ups
about and when I see you going back and
forth with people on Twitter hypocrisy
and that's the main thing usually that
comedians call out so when it comes to
faith so your faith is just your faith
to you I sense is just something private
you don't it's you're not even defining
what your faith is really right no I'm
not I mean if anyone wants to talk to me
about that I will but generally I my
faith is such that I don't pretend to
know all the answers and they often say
the opposite of faith is doubt I think
that's rubbish I think doubt is an
integral part of faith the opposite of
faith is certainty and I trust anybody
who's searching for the truth I
generally don't trust people who claim
they have it right so it's interesting
because me and you were sort of
splitting hairs on this I would say I'm
not a believer I wouldn't believe in
something without evidence but that said
I don't mind I know a lot of a lot of
atheists don't like people don't like
religious people or think that they're
really just diluted or whatever it is
and to me I would go with sort of what
you just said which is I don't mind if
someone's religious because I won't
pretend to be more moral than anyone or
living some saw a better life than
anyone else I just don't want them
pushing it on me or beheading me or put
throwing gays off roofs yeah I don't
want them using their personal faith as
an excuse to put somebody else down
and that's something I take very
seriously there is no part of the Bible
you can ever use to justify
discrimination against LGBT people and I
have this debate not infrequently again
there's no part of the Bible anyone can
honestly use to justify any sort of
discrimination and and when you're
starting to use Jesus when you're
starting to use Christianity as a
cloaking device for douchebaggery that's
what I have to call you out again
I've known wonderful conservative
religious people I think that very often
conservative Christians can be more
liberal with kindness than lots of
liberals you'll find a lot more
liberality of warmth and love at certain
you know Baptist meetings than you'll
find at Upper Eastside cocktail parties
so but but for me I'm in love with the
mystery yeah and and my definition of
God does not involve a man with a penis
and um you know I think that the Bible
the main character the Bible Jesus is a
guy who has spoken parable in metaphor I
don't know why it's so hard to read the
Bible as parable in metaphor there's a
lot of truth in the Bible not
necessarily a lot of facts yeah all
right I feel good about our start here
we sort of see this a little bit
differently but I respect where you're
coming from and that's sort of what both
of us yeah I just want to be big enough
to sucker people into myself no you're
quite good at it and by wearing all
black and with the long hair the whole
thing's very effective thank you very
much I've got a beautiful compound and I
want to invite all of your viewers down
you'll have to turn over some account
numbers and we're ropes but it's a
really a great safe community I think
you'll love what we do there yeah well
we'll put the link in the description
down below don't worry about that
okay so let's let's shift a little bit
to comedy Before we jump right into
politics so when did you really decide
okay I've got something to say and
people need to hear it because that's a
that's a crazy thing for a person to do
and I say that as someone that has done
stand-up for a long time
well I don't know if anyone needs to
hear anything I do I never really felt
that I just knew that um the first time
I saw George Carlin lies he made me feel
less alone and and I knew I wanted to do
what he did I wanted to come now
and and rail against injustice and
nonsense and lies but I didn't want to
just be a propagandist I wanted to do it
creatively I wanted to find ways to be
funny and and make it entertaining
and I've always tried to adhere to a
principle of entertaining first
informative second did preachy last
which is easier on stage and it is on
Twitter but I've always you know Carlin
was really good for me I was a fan it is
before I saw him live but once I saw him
lives I knew that that's what I wanted
to do and I so admired how he went after
politicians and religious leaders and
and just creeps in general and did it
using humor rather than hate or or just
propaganda and so for me I love doing
stand-up it's just silly and nonsense
but I also I also really love to uh to
work out logic through penis jokes
that's my morality yeah well you know to
me the the real beauty of Carlin was
that he was the most political you could
possibly be and yet at the same time
very rarely commented on politics of the
day you know what I mean like right now
if he was alive I don't think he would
be commenting that much on the the
racehorse that were all caught in of you
know the Trump Hillary Bernie this that
the other thing but he would be
commenting on the bigger pieces of it
and you kind of you kind of take the
same approach yeah I don't know I mean
you know he spoke extensively about the
Reagan administration he talked a lot
about Clinton versus Dole I mean if you
listen to the albums from the 80s so
what am i doing in New Jersey and and
then of course I think jamming jamming
in New York is his best album and back
in town the one that's followed it is
almost as good I think he would have lit
up the two but even like you were all
disease was an album where he talked
about bush and and you know he talked a
lot about supporting governor Bush after
9/11 even though he didn't like him he
would only call him governor Bush I mean
Carlin right he didn't make his whole
sense about it but he he more or less
took on the the inner douchebag and all
of us and politicians were very often
the starting point room to jump off into
into just social hypocrisy that the
politicians are just figureheads of so
he did single out and Clinton he went
off on a lot
I once saw him in Vegas where he was
railing against the Bush family and just
said I hope the whole family dies in an
airplane fire and people were walking
out in droves but it was a pleasure to
watch him work out his material that way
and separate the anger from the humor
anger from the out rage because angry
doesn't work in comedy but outraged us
right you got to get right to that line
and tow it properly and then you can
tell some people the truth because if
you're telling the truth and you're
being funny that's good but if you tell
them the truth and you're not that's
when the pitchforks come yeah I think so
I mean Billy Wilder set a date Billy
Wilder said if you're gonna tell people
the truth
make it funny or they'll kill you and I
keep that quote around yeah there you go
all right so let's let's jump into some
political stuff you are
through-and-through liberal you're one
of my left friends that I still
understand a lot of what I've been doing
on the show I've lost a lot of my people
on the left but I consider you a good
liberal do you consider yourself a
liberal does that have any meaning to
you anymore that the words I don't know
what to tell you the truth I mean ten
years ago I got called a liberal because
I supported gay marriage I supported
decriminalizing marijuana
I thought bushes economic plans weren't
gonna work and I was against the Iraq
war it turns out I wasn't a liberal I
was prematurely mainstream right and
throughout history I think prematurely
mainstream is is what liberals have been
they've been the ones who fight for
social change generally but you know
everyone I know every interesting person
I know is liberal in some areas and
conservative and others if you're all
just one of the other thing it doesn't
mean anything you become a guy at a Star
Trek convention so I get asked this
question and I don't really know what
liberal means anymore but when I read
the dictionary definition of the word I
aspire to be that you know like I was on
the show on Fox News and they kept
trying to get me to admit I was a
liberal and I said I aspire to be a
liberal the same way I aspire to be a
Christian I don't know if I would ever
self-identify as either of those two
words yeah well I love that and you
weren't connected to us on skype when I
did the intro to the show but I actually
took the deck the literal definition the
dictionary definition of liberal and I
read it out and it's someone who's I
basically if you're
Diaz are evolving if you're willing to
challenge the status quo then then you
are a liberal and it's so funny to me I
remember back in 1992 when I was 12
years old and we were doing a mock
election when Dukakis was running
against George HW Bush and George what's
that I was 80 I'm sorry that was 88 that
was 88 92 was the was Clinton and and
George HW said you're a liberal and
Dukakis that I'm not a liberal and that
was the Democrat because the liberal
became was a dirty word back then yeah
for that I mean by the end of that
campaign
Dukakis finally said yes I'm a liberal
in this tradition of JFK and all that
and Bush celebrated and said a wonder of
wonders he finally admits it and I give
Bush credit for making a word that means
empathetic and open-minded and caring
about the least of us a word that pretty
much sums up Jesus if you go by the
dictionary definition and and Bush
senior I think it's the most credit for
turning it into a dirty word you know I
mean I mean there's no way you can say
that Jesus wasn't a liberal if you go by
the dictionary definition of the term
yeah and he certainly you know they they
didn't the state didn't put him to death
and the conservative religious bosses of
their day didn't put him to death
because he didn't rock the boat no he
did not want change right this is a guy
who wanted some change exactly by that
same token you know that that definition
you bring up it's the greatest proof
that we don't have a liberal media our
friends on the right of thought are
saying it's a liberal media and I've
just been like well this year is proven
if the media was liberal I mean for a
while we've known if they were liberal
they'd probably cover an anti-war rally
as much as they cover a tea party event
but if the media was liberal I think
they would have given Bernie Sanders a
bit more then 180th the airtime they've
given Donald Trump the media
profit-driven there are a lot of
liberals who work in the media but the
media itself is ratings driven it's
profit driven that's not necessarily a
bad thing that's just how it is and a
lot of liberals and conservatives can't
admit that right so I love that you made
that point because yes it's profit
driven and people want clicks and people
want views we all understand that
don't know what a better model would be
I don't know that the government coming
in and saying everyone should have
exactly equal time I don't know that
that really makes sense I'm not a huge
government guy so I don't really love
that and at the end of the day if more
people are watching Trump and he's just
using the system it's kind of shitty but
it's sort of where we're at like what
else what else can we do like the
restore the Fairness Doctrine we could
have more than one PBS we could have a
PBS for liberals and a PBS for
conservatives I think we could have
presidential debates every week on PBS
mm-hmm
where it's not about profit you know I
don't resent a corporate media from
having to be responsible to their
shareholders that's just how the culture
in the industry has evolved and once you
admit that you know Donald Trump seems
to think that all these ratings all this
airtime mean people love him what Trump
and I think a lot of folks in the media
haven't realised is a lot of these
ratings that Trump generates is because
a large number of people are actually
hate watching him he is the true
detective season 2 of politics and
watching wait you know to see how
horrible he is the way you slow down for
a car wreck I don't think that
necessarily translates into lows I
stopped watching true detective season 2
after one episode unfortunately the
country hasn't quite caught up to me on
that I staged the bitter end like a you
know I'll never get those 10 hours back
but you know I do think that that MSNBC
is doing great in their ratings now but
I think it may be because people are
just fascinated that this Trump thing is
actually happening I mean as a novelty
act historically it's never happened
before it'll probably never happen again
and so in that sense I think it's
newsworthy in much the same way I think
the Malaysian plane going missing or the
OJ case was newsworthy these are things
that have never happened before yeah and
really begrudge the population for
leaning in to watch a spectacle that our
grandparents couldn't have imagined yeah
so isn't it a little bit of both with
Trump though because there's obviously
the spectacle and the sort of carnival
atmosphere and all that but at the same
time I read the other day that I think
at this point he has more votes than any
other Republican in the primaries or at
least he's going to certainly break
Romney's record or george w bush's
record by the time california runs
around i think it's more than reagan
already now part of that is just
demographics change and all that kinda
stuff but the point is that people are
action people are actually voting for
him it's not just 1% now approval of the
GOP that means Dave that Donald Trump is
so popular he's got fifty percent of
twenty eight percent the American Legion
right Hillary and Bernie combined have
gotten more votes than trouble
you